6. Signs you might be hyper independent from trauma.
No. 1. You tend to be the ruler in your family,
meaning that in your house,
you tend to take on all the responsibilities,
schedule all of the things,
feel accountable for every single thing that happens
because time has taught you that
you cannot rely on anyone.
Number two you've probably lost somebody,
whether through their passing
or them leaving you,
walking out of your life at some point,
and decided that you will never need anybody again
because you did not have support, the tools,
or the understanding of how to work through that grief.
So you would rather be alone
than suffer that heartache and that loss again.
Number three
you probably grew up as a caregiver,
and you may have taken on the responsibility of raising
or protecting your siblings,
so being in charge is just second nature
because you really just didn't have a choice.
Number four
my personal favorite
is that you probably are hyper independent if
at some point
you decided that you would be responsible
for every single thing in your life
so that nobody could let you down
and nothing could go wrong that
you weren't in control of.
No. 5. You probably are hyper independent
if you decided to push through
because it was too hard to feel your feelings,
or they were so invalidated
that it was easier to just keep moving forward
and have a plan of action
than It was to sit and deal with the fact
that nobody cared how you felt.
And number six,
you're probably hyper independent
if you grew up in a household
where there was no emotional,
physical, or mental support,
meaning that
you basically just had to fend for yourself.